Der Flugverkehr verursacht horrende CO2-Emissionen
und andere Treibhausgase, die das Klima nachhaltig
schädigen und die Erderwärmung antreiben.
Doch auch die Kondensstreifen, die beim Fliegen
am Himmel entstehen, sind nicht ohne.
Ein deutsches Forschungsteam hat jetzt herausgefunden,
dass sich der durch Kondensstreifen verursachte
Klimaeffekt bis zum Jahr 2050 - ACHTUNG - verdreifachen
wird.
Das Problem wird also immer größer!
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos - abonniert den Kanal,
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts herzlich willkommen!
Sie sehen eigentlich ziemlich harmlos aus;
sind aber alles andere als das: Kondensstreifen.
Gemeint sind damit die langen, schmalen weißen
Streifen, die Flugzeuge am blauen Himmel hinterlassen.
Chemisch gesehen handelt es sich dabei um
langgezogene Eiswolken.
In einer Flughöhe von bis zu 10.000 Metern
herrschen etwa minus 40 Grad Celsius.
Bei der Verbrennung von Kerosin entstehen
Abgase wie Ruß und andere Schwebstoffe, die
somit in die Atmosphäre gelangen.
Sie werden in der Fachsprache auch als “Kristallisationskeime”
genannt.
Denn an diesen Partikeln lagern sich zunächst
Wassermoleküle ab, die dann Eiskristalle
bilden.
Diese sehen wir dann in Form sichtbarer Eiswolken!
Manchmal können diese Kondensstreifen aber
auch zu weißlichen fein strukturierten Schleierwolken
heranwachsen, die man in der Fachsprache dann
als “Cirren” bezeichnet.
Diese können sogar tagelang am Himmel bleiben.
Und das bleibt nicht ohne Folgen, denn sie
versperren den Wärmestrahlen ihren Weg ins
Weltall hinaus.
Heißt also im Klartext: Wärme, die vom Erdboden
aufsteigt, wird wieder nach unten reflektiert.
Die Folge: Die obere Erdatmosphäre erwärmt
sich.
Und dieser Effekt hat enorme Folgen.
Diese Wolkenbildung ist ein echter Klimakiller.
Deutlich mehr sogar als das CO2, das durch
Flugzeuge in derselben Zeit ausgestoßen wird.
Und so trägt nach Schätzungen des Weltklimarates
der weltweite Flugverkehr mit etwa fünf Prozent
zur menschengemachten Erderwärmung bei.
Der Effekt, den die Kondensstreifen zu verantworten
haben, ist hier schon berücksichtigt.
Das ist eine Menge und vor allem weitaus mehr
als von der Luftfahrtindustrie immer wieder
gesagt wird.
Doch vielleicht nicht genug?!
Genau davor warnt jetzt ein Forschungsteam
des Deutschen Zentrums für Luft- und Raumfahrt
(DLR) aus Köln.
Denn die Entwicklung des weltweiten Flug-Aufkommens
wird sich aktuellen Prognosen zufolge alle
15 Jahre verdoppeln.
Vom Jahr 2006 bis zum Jahr 2050 wird er sich
also vervierfachen.
In ihrer Studie interessierten sich die drei
Atmosphären-Forscherinnen vor allem für
die Auswirkungen der Kondensstreifen auf die
Strahlungsbilanz und den daraus resultierenden
Temperaturveränderungen am Boden.
Als Basis zogen sie dazu ein globales Atmosphärenmodell
heran, das in dem einen Szenario von einer
mäßigen Erwärmung der Erde ausgeht und
in einem anderen Szenario von einer drastischen
Erderwärmung.
Und das Ergebnis der Fachleute ist erschreckend:
Der aktuellen Studie zufolge wird sich der
Klimaeffekt durch Kondensstreifen mit dem
zunehmenden Flugverkehr bis zum Jahr 2050
etwa verdreifachen!
Der Strahlungsantrieb, der durch Cirruswolken
ausgelöst wird, könnte von den derzeitigen
49 Megawatt (mW) pro Quadratmetern auf 159
mW pro Quadratmeter im Jahr 2050 ansteigen.
Das ist die Energie, die sie dann abgeben
werden und die konkret zu höheren Temperaturen
führt.
Die aktuellen Berechnungen beruhen auf vielen
verschiedenen Annahmen.
Unter anderem gehen Fachleute davon aus, dass
vor allem der Flugverkehr in Afrika und Südostasien
extrem zunehmen wird.
Technische Entwicklungen werden in den nächsten
Jahren zudem dazu führen, dass der Trend
hin zu steigenden Flughöhen geht.
Auch das hat Folgen auf die Bildung von Kondensstreifen,
denn größere Höhen führen dazu, dass nicht
nur der Luftwiderstand, sondern auch der Treibstoffverbrauch
abnimmt.
Entscheidend für die Bildung von Kondensstreifen
ist allerdings auch die Luftfeuchtigkeit.
Relativ gesehen würden so in den gemäßigten
Breiten WENIGER Kondensstreifen entstehen
- bedingt durch eine geringe Luftfeuchtigkeit.
Der aktuellen Studie zufolge könnte sich
der Strahlungsantrieb durch Kondenstreifen-
Cirruswolken in Europa somit bis zum Jahr
2050 sogar um 48 Prozent reduzieren.
Der Anstieg der Flughöhe würde in Regionen
mit einer hohen Luftfeuchtigkeit aber für
einen gegenteiligen Effekt sorgen: die Bildung
von Cirrus-Wolken nämlich.
Auf den Punkt gebracht gehen die drei Autorinnen
der aktuellen Studie davon aus, dass vor allem
über Asien ein Anstieg der Kondensstreifen
zu erwarten ist.
Fachleute sind sich übrigens bislang noch
nicht ganz einig, wie wieviel stärker sich
Kondensstreifen tatsächlich auf den Klimawandel
auswirken.
Klar ist, dass sich die obere Atmosphäre
durch die menschen-verursachten Wolken aufheizt.
Denn die Kondensstreifen sorgen zum einen
dafür, dass die Wärme, die von der Erde
aufsteigt, zurück reflektiert wird.
Wie in einem Treibhaus eben.
Doch die Wolken haben zum anderen wohl auch
noch einen anderen Effekt: Denn sie filtern
die Sonneneinstrahlung zumindest zum Teil
auch ab und kühlen so die Atmosphäre.
Doch welcher Effekt ist größer?!
Aktuelle Forschungsarbeiten legen nahe, dass
die wärmende Wirkung die kühlende im Mittel
überwiegt.
Dazu Lisa Bock vom DLR: “Die Kondensstreifen-Wolken
selbst, sowie ihre Einflüsse auf die Erdoberfläche,
sind laufende Forschungsthemen.
Bisher gibt es noch große Unsicherheiten
über die Gesamt-Klimaauswirkungen dieser
Wolken insbesondere bezüglich ihrer Auswirkungen
auf die Oberflächentemperatur.
Aber eines ist klar: Sie erwärmen die Atmosphäre."
Laut der aktuellen Studie ist es dringend
notwendig, emissionsarmes Fliegen durch technische
Innovationen schnell möglich zu machen.
Denn dadurch könnte letzten Endes auch die
Bildung von Kondensstreifen vermindert werden.
Denn schließlich hängen Größe und Anzahl
der Eiskristalle von den Rußpartikel-Emissionen
der Flugzeugtriebwerke ab.
Doch selbst die Reduktion von Rußemissionen
könnte längst nicht mehr ausreichend sein.
Dazu die Wissenschaftlerin Ulrike Burkhardt:
“Selbst wenn ein 90-prozentiger Rückgang
der emittierten Partikel gelingt, wird es
wahrscheinlich nicht ausreichen, um die Klimaauswirkung
von Kondensstreifen auf das Niveau von 2006
zu begrenzen”.
Die Autorinnen der aktuellen Studie haben
zudem eine klare Forderung.
Sie kritisieren, dass die Auswirkungen von
Kondensstreifen auf das globale Klimasystem
bislang noch nicht in Emissionshandel-Abkommen
berücksichtigt werden.
Dazu Lisa Bock: “Es ist aber wichtig, die
signifikanten Auswirkungen von Nicht-CO2-Emissionen
wie den Kondensstreifen-Zirren auf das Klima
zu untersuchen.
Auch diese Effekte müssen bei der Einrichtung
von Emissionshandelssystemen (...) berücksichtigt
werden”.
Schließlich könnten diese Handelsabkommen
dazu führen, dass Flugzeugemissionen beschränkt
werden.
Eine ganz andere Frage ist noch.
Sind die Kondensstreifen Chemtrails?
Geht von Ihnen eine chemische Gefahr aus?
Breaking Lab hat dazu intensiv recherchiert
und die ein oder andere überraschende Antwort.
Anklicken, anschauen und Breaking Lab abonnieren.
Hammer Kanal.
Es lohnt sich!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!